the explosive new york times report on
the tax situation of u.s president
donald trump
is raising some uncomfortable questions
for germany's largest lender deutsche
bank namely
why did deutsche bank loan mr trump two
billion dollars
at the same time other banks including
all u s
lenders were not willing to do so and
while deutsche bank may be handling
those loans
we cannot say tonight who or what is
behind
that money in other words we don't know
who owns the debt
of u.s president donald trump and adding
to this puzzle
is the role played by the son of a
former
u.s supreme court justice justin kennedy
son of former justice anthony kennedy
was a division head and contact for
donald trump at deutsche bank
kennedy was close to the then future
president
at the same time that he was lending
money to mr trump
now the optics of this are horrible for
deutsche bank so bad that author and
political scientist norman ornstein
tweeted yesterday if i were deutsche
bank executives who gave loans to trump
when no one else would
including anthony kennedy's son i would
be
very very nervous right now
all right let's speak with the man who
voiced that opinion norman ornstein
joins me he's a political scientist at
the american enterprise institute he's
also an author and editor at the
atlantic
it's good to have you on the day mr
ornstein
so do you think deutsche bank executives
do they have something to hide
we don't know what they have to hide but
as you say the optics
are terrible but it's more than just the
optics
we know from these tax returns that
donald trump
was in dire financial shape
had very few assets and deep deep
liabilities
was concealing information about those
assets and if you look at some of these
tax returns
the only logical explanation when he
came up with bundles of cash and was
buying golf courses all over the place
golf courses which now in many cases are
hemorrhaging losses
it looks like money laundering where did
that money come from and what role did
deutsche bank play
in facilitating all of that and why
was a reputable bank lending huge sums
of money to somebody
widely viewed everywhere as a
significant credit risk
and then you throw in something else
that you alluded to but didn't quite get
to
justice anthony kennedy retired
prematurely
and to enable donald trump to pick a
much
younger individual and that younger
individual
was anthony kennedy's protege brett
kavanaugh very controversial and
something that's altered the
nature of the supreme court what was
going on there
given the personal relationship and
business relationship
apparently between the younger kennedy
and donald trump through deutsche bank
there's an awful lot here to unpack and
unravel wow a lot of it looks bad
yeah it does look bad and i mean it
sounds like if i'm understanding you
right that i mean at least the optics
here it looks like
there could be a connection between
justin kennedy's
relationship with donald trump loaning
donald trump
money and the decision by supreme court
justice anthony kennedy to retire early
in other
words in exchange for loan money there
was a guarantee
of the ability to impact the future of
the supreme court
am i understanding you correctly
we you know we don't know we can only
infer
things from this but none of it looks
good
and it's all tied together and
considering that deutsche bank has had
other issues including
russian money coming through and being
laundered in some fashion
we can connect some dots here that don't
sound good it requires
a lot of investigation and that's why
i tweeted first that if i were those
executives at deutsche bank i'd be
nervous right now and then i followed
with
it's probably time for the southern
district of new york the federal
prosecutors who've been investigating
some of these areas
and the district attorney and attorney
general in the state of new york
to depose young mr kennedy and perhaps
begin to get to the bottom of it
well that's what's at issue right now
isn't it um who owns
these loans that donald trump has to pay
back more than 400
million u.s dollars i mean we don't know
but
maybe some executives at deutsche bank
maybe they know
one would think uh that you know you can
follow
you know tongue-in-cheek i said we need
to follow the rubles
but we don't know for sure i will tell
you that a very good journalist
associated with the new yorker
adam davidson who wrote a long piece
about
connections with azerbaijan and money
laundering going through
uh some of the figures there the
miscreants there
which apparently indicated a great
interest in golf courses
you know might have some ties here as
well and of course we also
have reason to believe that trump in
decades passed
had gotten loans from russian sources
if you look at the president's
relationship with vladimir putin and the
actions that he's taken
including the promise to withdraw troops
from
germany that serve the interests of uh
mr putin and russia
we have even more to be concerned about
you know our constitution
uh has in it two causes that we call
emoluments clauses
right the main one is to prevent a major
figure
especially a president from getting
anything of value from a foreign
interest in a way that might compromise
america's national interest and its
foreign policy
there's an awful lot here that we have
questions about that
are vital to america's national interest
yep
and we've we've tried to get comments
from deutsche bank but it's it's
been incredibly difficult to get them to
talk about this and
as you say it may be up to u.s
prosecutors to
issue subpoenas before we can actually
get anything from
deutsche bank what do you say
and you know the problem we have right
now is that those prosecutors
are mostly federal prosecutors
associated with a justice department
when we have an attorney general who is
in donald trump's pocket and basically
acting more as his attorney
than the attorney for the united states
but the notoriously independent southern
district of new york may
move ahead and the state of new york uh
which also has direct interests in this
including
questions of tax fraud uh that president
trump might well have engaged in
um can issue its own subpoenas
so i i think we're only at the beginning
of a story
that is not going to probably be
resolved until after this next election
and if donald trump wins again it may
not be resolved uh
for a very very long time if at all
norman ornstein political scientist at
the american enterprise institute and
editor at the atlantic mr orenstein we
appreciate your time and your valuable
insights tonight
thank you thank you